I want to bring now by phone Republican
senator Rick Scott of Florida where
again the senator you've chosen to let
the voting continue in your state not
you personally but everybody together is
leadership why was that decision made it
was a decision of the governor but in
Florida what you have is you have early
voting you have and your mail-in ballot
and then you have voting Election Day
our supervisor elections are looked at
elected by County so I think every
person in that County each county can
reach out to their supervisor elections
and ask them how they're making sure
that they're you know they're going to
be safe or the poll Watchers need to be
safe we need to have social distancing
and and then the people come in to vote
so my expectation is every supervisor
election in Florida has done that you
know you are a former Florida governor
you wear several hats and that's
something that people can lean on I
would imagine as a resource for you just
knowing you the way that I do that you
would help out has governor de Santos
reached out and said do we need to take
a look at this we as Americans are being
told to stay home as much as possible
does this fly in the face of that has he
talked to you no I've never had the
opportunity to talk to Governor De
Santis but you know it's a decision that
they made and my expectation is being
Harris they've got to keep these poor
mean well first off it's poll workers
they have to be safe and a lot of these
poll workers are the age group that you
know they're theirs they're at risk so I
my expectation is that these supervisors
or supervisors election have done their
job that's an interesting point about
them fitting right into the lane of
those we're trying to protect the
president weighed in on governor DeWine
calling off o hyo's primary today let's
watch and I'll get your reaction senator
we're going by the rule of 10 as opposed
to 50 and it's pretty tough
I would say probably you could violate
that if you wanted to for an election I
just think an election is a very special
thing he's gonna chose he chose a
different date I think a date sometime
in June but that would be a decision
that would be made by him senator well
I'm agin I I don't know how there's a
setup but my expectation is you look at
you know just on on the TV you look at
how many people were there I mean did
they do everybody's make sure no one has
fevers
did you know did they do proper social
distancing I think you have to do if you
think this through and how do you how do
you make sure people are safe and you
know and then your poll Watchers in
power for workers and how do you make
sure people come in say I know I'm gonna
be safe yeah when you bring up some
really salient points you know Ohio is
not the only state to cancel we saw
Georgia and albeit now some of the
others that have canceled are a little
bit farther out than we are now but
looking ahead how do you think just big
picture how do you see this playing out
I mean this is difficult as the
president said we could be in this mode
of trying to keep the numbers down and
flatten out that contagion curve for a
few more months to the summer
well here's I think I think every
whether we're talking about what's
happening with the economy or with
elections everything comes down to how
are we dealing with coronavirus I think
we have to bake even more extreme
measures than where we are we have got
to get up testing sites now by Friday
every county in this country ought to
have a mobile testing site so people can
one get a test and two we don't have a
chance of instructing our health care
workers which are hopefully going to
take care of us if we get sick we've got
to close our borders I mean that's the
most fun thing to do but it do it and
then these governors have gotten a
ticket responsibility and say I'm gonna
stop I'm gonna stop you know this yeah
I'm gonna make sure we you know prevent
large social interactions we got a I'm
worried about a supply line I'm worried
about our drugs I'm worried about price
gouging we at every level of government
we've got to step up and say this is
bigger than what we thought because I
think a lot of people didn't think this
was
as big I've been talking about this for
two months this is you can watch what's
happening China I know you have and I
mean we've gotta be we gotta take this
more seriously you know it's all and
there's a julie me we have to do this
in the end I gotta take care of my
family you gotta take care of yours and
then we are churches everybody's got to
get involved in that yeah we're part of
a bigger family
Team USA as I like to say the whole time
you were talking we were showing some of
that polling video now it's video from a
little bit earlier and I was thinking
about what you're saying that that's
facing with the booths right next to
each other that is a big job at the
polls today and you pointed out some
things that they needed to be doing
former governor of Florida now senator
Rick Scott appreciate your time today
thank you
I think there's have a good day